welcome to this video playing Thomas
tellers from Italy and the Trump netted
me some nice victories so I'm going to
try it again is this is a line that I
saw recently and it is a thingy 5 is
right I'm not sure this also e5 but yeah
this is this is somewhat comparable to
the Vogon young gambit so I'm going for
that like queen bee to Bishop t2 this is
a very very similar and he's scrubbing
but here i wonder if i go might be five
immediately is this a move might be five
mighty 497 is made night a six the Queen
does not have many squares and not sure
this is danger it anyway so let's just
get ahead okay um fYI guess still if he
takes d5 i play e5 which is terrible for
black ed 5e 59 moves 95 and I have a
fantastic knight on d5 yes this is a bit
more like it but this looks a lot like
my game against the opponent before that
the Sun Alexa seems to be dangerous for
black very dangerous so Bishop c4 baby
takes Knight eggs laughs it's a oh I can
just take it six now and I will this
must be good for why I'm just getting to
e6 and if you place the night no I g54
night f7 or Bishop f7 well I'm getting
fantastic positions with this opening
maybe I should play the trump really
seriously that's funny you never get
this kind of stuff after 12 moves with
the with 193 what I often play I mean
rarely at least I have one my fair share
of quick games with it but so um check
check first so that the King has to move
and or something I mean age 6 looks a
little bit annoying but maybe this year
for light f7
yeah why not I can maybe do this age 69
f seven looks quite terrible also I'm
just able to take e six and play 96 yeah
the worst thing is for black I don't
even I'm not even a porn down how is
this Queenie 525 coming
tion till night f7 here why not so is
giving up material here I think can take
this rook and what then you will take
yeah I take a look this is just a rock
ready okay the check on g3 but it's
really just a check here I can can take
here jack ok I've got Queen f3 all the
time if he goes Knight g4 or maybe even
9594 is so a little bit more forceful
huh maybe I still should have played
differently he can take e six now and
maybe castle long yeah I haven't he
hasn't moved his King yet so maybe maybe
there was probably something something
easier and okay but nighty to hear my
tea too he does not have a check here or
anything
I mean one good thing is i'm a rook up
so I can return some material and so be
okay I was thinking I wait a king
goodnight f7 why can go nite f7 here and
92 possibly 92 hmm okay my original idea
was to just take F to him and Bishop f4
for some for some simplification but I
here and can give this check on h1 but
nighttime when I'm a safe he okay water
wacky turn of events IAM can still take
if he takes d to f king g 1 which is
probably wrongly easy okay I don't know
Nyjah for stuff like that Nyjah form
yeah it just takes them ok we'll take
with this
yeah the problem is I'm not coordinated
well my nightie ahanks and all kinds of
stuff is hanging there's also Queen III
check all of a sudden
okay Wow check amazing
amazing how much countably play God I
mean he takes d5 was really really
stupid I guess it still should should
win i think but now you can take the
night i totally forgot about that I know
check yeah and this on top of all of it
oh my god right at seven I mean maybe
it's not that bad check now you can keep
it here i have got eight seconds oh man
check now I is playing completely
erratic moves Stratos to irritate me
check check check
white for fence on town yeah okay yeah
so this was really really stupid I mean
I'm just like totally winning totally
winning yeah and probably I'm winning
for a very long time but what you know
what the underside needed is that this
night seafoam was coming here yeah it's
the plus 7 and whatnot but it gets
increasingly tricky here night f7 is
winning which I thought I didn't really
see that that this is so so problematic
I a queen 22 still wins totally and this
this is losing not to this but Bishop
yeah this is now okay three is still
winning I did you see any of that it's
just a total mess that was unnecessary
and tea again I'm winning it just a
totally totally crappy game from both
sides Queen g5 now still wins checked
here again I'm winning and so on young
Queen a five now wins I'm just a piece
up he didn't even try to review that
really check I was mostly trying to win
on time even here King you two wins oh
man what a bad game yeah I only had 13
seconds it yeah i mean this totally
messy position is not really my my
strong suit but i really got irritated
him dad hurts him losing against this
kind of position especially I mean who
are no assistance is just allowing that
but okay I mean Jeff I don't know what I
did him wow thanks for watching